dylan sprouse breaks his silence after  his ex-girlfriend claimed he cheated  [Music]  dylan is clearing up his side of the  story  days after the 25 year old actors former  lady  Dana Fraser shocked fans with a crying  selfie on Instagram that read when you  find out your boyfriend cheated on you  now he's addressing her claims in a  lengthy Twitter rant writing in part  quote the truth always has two sides and  those sides have motivations and those  motivations despite how cloudy they  currently seem are private the former  Disney star who is pretty private when  it comes to his personal life added  quote this is complicated and it will  remain complicated but those who know me  and who have known me know well enough  what kind of person I am  [Music]